[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
is to provide nutritional education only
this program is not meant to take the
place of your primary care physician the
FDA requires us to let you know that our
products are not meant to treat prevent
diagnose or cure any diseases as an
empowered individual you have options
available we are honored to have one of
the founding fathers of epigenetics here
to guide us with the best options to
obtain or maintain Optimal Health Dr
Joel Wallach welcome to daily with Doc
and Becca
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
the content of this program is to
provide nutritional education only this
program is not meant to take the place
of your primary care physician the FDA
requires us to let you know that our
products are not meant to treat prevent
diagnose or cure any diseases as an
empowered individual you have options
available we are honored to have one of
the founding fathers of epigenetics here
to guide us with the best options to
obtain or maintain Optimal Health Dr
Joel Wallach welcome to daily with Doc
and Becca
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
is to provide nutritional education only
this program is not meant to take the
place of your primary care physician the
FDA requires us to let you know that our
products are not meant to treat prevent
diagnose or cure any diseases as an
empowered
all right thank you so much Rousseau and
Sanchez if it wasn't for co-hosts this
whole thing would just not fall into
place but welcome everybody to daily
with Doc my name is Becca dukes and I'm
honored and privileged to be the host uh
Hostess of this program where we are
bringing to you nutritional information
from a doctor that is not an overnight
show up he has been doing us and
teaching us and not just teaching it but
he did the research that led him to be
able to link over 600 different poor
health conditions to nutrient
deficiencies
can you imagine
at least nine to ten different nutrients
or different
symptoms poor health symptoms that are
associated to even just one mineral
and then we've got 60 minerals that the
body requires
so 60 times 10 that's 600 folks there's
over 600 different poor health
conditions that are linked to
nutritional deficiencies and Dr Wallach
has just been absolutely
gung-ho not I mean he's relentless
he doesn't and hasn't wavered on the
importance of these 90 essential
nutrients for decades decades now as
research comes along and he's finding
okay there's more things that are
actually contributing to poor health
that are being
pushed as being healthy
and when he looks at the research he
looks at the data he looks at the things
that a pathologist would look at
a scientist would look at he is bringing
to us more and more information that
allows us to be empowered as individuals
and take control of our own health so
with that being said Dr Wallach I know
you've got a great topic for us
so please go ahead and share with us
what it is that is on your heart and
mind today let me get you added up here
where did he go I'm here
you're here well I'm so glad that you're
here here we are there you go see
co-hosts they help make everything
happen so thank you so much Ruth Ellen
for grabbing that Dr Wallach
we do a lot of a lot of talking
and there's a lot of times that we are
um communicating with people through
private consultations through public
questions
and they talk about or they think
that it's okay for different symptoms
to be occurring because of their age
is that true
no age does not cause any disease okay
and of course
um that's that's
um one of the fallacies of the medical
profession oh
you know you're getting white here
because you're getting older you got to
expect that oh you have arthritis
because you're getting older you have to
expect that you're getting high blood
pressure because you're getting old you
have to expect that you're getting
diabetes because you have high blood
pressure and and other things so you
might expect the diabetes thing to pop
on uh none of that's true all of those
are nutritional deficiencies you heard
me they're all nutritional deficiencies
when a doctor starts talking to you
about them being
a genetic disease your whole family is
going to have it in blah blah blah blah
that's when you have to say Okay I'm
going to excuse myself please cancel all
my further appointments because you and
I are done because you know nothing
about disease if you're saying those
things which is I can take them to court
if they want okay because I haven't beat
them every time okay we have some great
stuff coming out here in the near future
I'm so excited about this I just have to
bite my tongue so I don't tell you about
it it's too soon okay but what I want to
do is talk about some of the common
things that afflict everybody
um
because let's just look at bones bones
are not poured concrete
bones are living things okay and
depending on what you eat what you don't
eat
Bones come and go
okay and so if your bones are going away
when you're a kid
the odds are you're eating oatmeal for
breakfast or Wheaties for breakfast or
Cheerios for breakfast or pancakes or
waffles
um
wheat noodles for lunch pizza crust made
from from a gluten wheat and that kind
of stuff it's one of those things where
you have to appreciate all these
diseases and of course the medical
system they're sitting back in their
chair and insurance pays for their
treatments surgery and drugs
insurance pays for their treatment
surgery and drugs and people are happy
oh my gosh the my pain I had for years
went away when they gave me those new
drugs I'm the first one on the in the
state to get it yeah you believe that
right okay
let's start out with some very common
stuff
um like arthritis osteoporosis each year
in America alone
the medical system
in America makes
626.8 billion dollars into treat
arthritis which is actually approaches
to the joints they get paid 2.3 trillion
dollars with a t
for treating
osteoporosis so the two together is
three trillion dollars
we're spending each year in America just
to treat the symptoms of arthritis
osteoporosis and it all goes into the
doctor's Pockets three trillion dollars
Wars don't cost that much okay and then
there's diabetes diabetes is not a
genetic disease that is very simple
nutritional deficiencies and so
um where we spend 342 billion dollars a
year just to treat the symptoms of
diabetes
and we're not even talking about some of
the spin-off stuff that happens when you
have chronic diabetes you have all these
other secondary issues that go along
with it okay and uh 342 billion so if
you have arthritis and diabetes you're
spending it a trillion dollars in
America right just to pay for treating
the symptoms of diabetes and arthritis
and then
another one of my favorites is obesity
we're spending 260 billion dollars a
year for obesity 260 billion dollars a
year for obesity
and we're spending only 131 billion
dollars a year for treating habit
pressure
okay asthma in kids and kids you know
under the age of um six years we're
spending 80 billion dollars a year to
treat the asthma and kids very simple
nutritional deficiencies
kidney dialysis 24 billion dollars a
year
okay very simple nutritional
deficiencies so what do you do
the first thing you do is you know you
get a hold of the book The Wallach
Revolution 75 years track record of
dealing with these various diseases and
how to deal with them some of the major
uh discoveries are in here 75 years and
some very famous people thank you Becca
some very famous people of course are
dealing with this and telling their
stories their personal stories we're
talking about 88 year old
let's see here the guy the guy is 88
years old okay
and he is Pat Boone 88 years old 25 I
think it's like 25 songs or maybe it's
20 songs over you know 25 million sold
or whatever this guy's amazing but he
had
um arthritis was a double knee
replacement we rebuilt him and quickly
and he started telling other people and
he helped Andy Young Who was the
Ambassador United Nations for the United
States and also the mayor of Atlanta he
helped him get rid of his
um arthritis so he didn't have to have a
double knee replacement
and then
um Danny Glover famous actor and
comedian okay he had all kinds of severe
things going on with his knees and his
hips but he also had
um seizures and so he got on our program
we got rid of seizures and we rebuilt
all his bones and everything remember
bones are not poured concrete they're
living things and so you know if you get
10 of those books or 10 of any of my
title books so you get a nice discount
so that's the Wallach Revolution 75-year
track record and all these people famous
people are jumping in because we helped
them and didn't charge him anything now
that freaks him out
we didn't charge him anything they could
pay for it okay now they paid for the
products but they they didn't pay for my
services you know we did it all for free
so I do the same thing for you I don't
charge you my for my services I don't
send you a bill like a doctor would do
okay
and then we have epigenetics which is
epigenics which is the summary of my
thesis which is in the Smithsonian
Institute of National Treasure thank you
and it's a picture of me in 1976 when I
discovered the first non-human cases of
cisiobrosis and Space Monkeys at
Yorkie's Primary Center in Emory
University Atlanta Georgia and I got
fired because I said it wasn't a genetic
thing it was easily reproduced we could
have a colony of monkeys with this we
could create a
research animals was it and they fired
me that's when I went back to school and
became a physician so let's look at some
of this stuff the first thing you need
to do when you have
the diagnosis of these diseases okay
we're talking about arthritis diabetes
heart disease
um osteoporosis
um habit pressure diabetes the first
thing you have to do is is get rid of
all the bad stuff now if you're taking
all these nutrients you're not going to
get those disease I've never had any of
these diseases
well in two months I'm 84 years old I
have never had any of these diseases
okay I can take on anybody put my size
and weight okay no matter how old they
are because you know I feel like I did
when I was in my 30s
okay so let's turn out with arthritis
and osteoporosis very common we spend
more money on treating arthritis
osteoporosis symptoms than any other
disease you know several of them
combined and so you need to get rid of
all the bad stuff no fried foods no
processed Meats no oils no glutens no
wheat to burn rhinos no sugar no
carbonate or drinks you know the diet
one's got to go and the carbonated water
needs to go so it can absorb minerals
and digest food you need to make stomach
acid so you need to take our either
seasoned salt from Australia or or
um salt from the Himalayan mountains or
Himalayan salt that's in now again oh my
gosh it's flying out the door okay
because 28 minerals in it and it's
really a great great thing to help you
digest food and absorb food and all your
cells and your body work okay and of
course your stomach makes stomach acid
and require sodium chloride salts any
doctor who tells you to not take salt
because you might get high blood
pressure again find a new doctor because
that doctor is killing people if he's
telling you to get away from Salt
because salt is an essential nutrient
that'd be like saying I know you have
pneumonia but you need to stay away from
oxygen no breathing anymore please okay
that's how stupid that is okay
so
um and again
um osteoporosis
is 2.3 trillion and together with
arthritis three trillion dollars we're
spending very simple you take the
healthy brain and heart pack you take
the hildebrain hard pack one per 100
pounds of body weight you throw in the
MSM to help rebuild cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue disc between
the vertebrae bone range bone itself
including the skull
and then you throw in the collagen
peptides two cancers a month for an
average size adult scoop with morning
breakfast scoop of evening breakfast and
then I would also
let's see here throw in the vitamin D3
because most people don't sit out in the
sun for three hours a day and get the
sunshine okay so you need a vitamin D3
to absorb all the minerals in the right
place
then let's jump on diabetes
diabetes in America let me tell you
there's 96 million pre-diabetics in
America 96 million pre-diabetics in
America this is just a money Trail
pouring into the doctor's pockets
type 2 diabetes makes up 98 to 99 of all
the diabetes we have okay type 1
diabetes is a is not a genetic thing
Mama's missing stuff when the pancreas
is being formed in the embryo and they
don't get enough of the beta cells to
make insulin and babies born with very
low insulin not because of genetic pain
but because the mother was deficient
during early pregnancy okay
but they do have to take some some
insulin all right but some in some but
they still to be taken the 90 essential
nutrients including
the healthy blood sugar pack okay which
has the sweeties in it according to body
weight does it tell you on the label
according to body weight and don't cold
turkey off your medication for diabetes
but as the blood sugar drops you can
slowly reduce the medication so that
within weeks or months or so you'll be
an ex-diabetic type 2 diabetes 98 of
them it's very simple nutritional
deficiency we spend 342 billion dollars
a year just treating type 2 diabetes
terrible that doesn't count all these
side effects on you and all the other
stuff that goes on secondary secondary
affects student diabetes
okay let's look at obesity obesity is
caused by mineral deficiencies causing
people to have a behavior called Pica
and you eat and you eat and you eat
trying to find whatever it is you're
missing that's why people get overweight
so you take our
and see her keto Shake one meal per day
it's not an add-on it's a meal replacer
okay it doesn't have to be the same meal
every day it comes in a straw and
chocolate so you can change it around a
little bit so you're not getting the
same flavor every day
and then you need to be taking I I'd go
ahead and take the Hildebrand heart pack
uh one per 100 pounds of body weight and
you know if you weigh 110 pounds you
divide it half and half you weigh 150
pounds or more you take
um four dose of breakfast photos at
dinner time and then uh you also want to
take our rebound or sports drink our
rebounder's first shrink okay which has
75 minerals and 25 items amino acids in
it Red Bull has only one mineral in it
magnesium we have 75 minerals in my Mass
from Missouri
75 is more than one okay and then have a
pressure and dialysis well dialysis
and when you're not urinating your blood
pressure is going up that kind of stuff
uh the doctors put you on dialysis and
they're waiting for somebody to die so
they can get a kidney for a kidney
transplant right well guess what while
you're waiting uh get remember you're
getting off all the bad foods that's
everybody's got to do that and then you
take two Health packs a month we've
already said that and you're going to
take the two healthy excuse me the two
um bottles of MSN take three three times
a day and then once you get two bottles
a month of our ultimate daily classic
tablet so three words ultimate daily
classic tablets ultimate daily classic
tablets take three at breakfast three
dinner time don't get off your high
blood pressure medication but as the
blood pressure begins to drop because
you're supposed to test yourself every
day as the blood pressure begins to drop
you can slowly reduce medication based
on the numbers and usually within weeks
The Habit pressure medicine is gone
you're not a high blood pressure patient
anymore
asthma and kids is a very simple little
nutritional deficiency of the essential
fatty acids you get them depending on
how little they are and get them on the
kids toddy you can get them on the
healthy brain and heart pack don't
forget if they're playing sports don't
forget the rebound
and then and when you give them the
um healthy brain and heart pack they're
getting the essential fatty acids okay
if you're going to give them if they're
little kids they're going to give them
the kids toddy I'd also add three of the
efas a day maybe one of the efas at
dinner time and at breakfast one Eva
Plus
okay
and that will give them what they need
and usually the asthma disappears in
days
okay kidney dialysis again ultimate
daily classic tablets kidney starts
functioning balances stops I have people
who haven't urinated in 10 years around
dialysis six days a week for 10 years
from Dallas is three days a week for 25
years before that
you know they couldn't get a kidney so
they just kept them on dialysis well we
got them on our program in two weeks
time they're urinating so they dropped
them down to dialysis three days a week
and in two more weeks are totally off of
dialysis and they never had to have
dialysis again because they're taking
their nutrients and everything's happy
so with that said I want to make sure
that everybody knows about this we've
covered a lot of stuff very fast here
okay
and all this of course is in the books
like uh the Walnut Revolution
epigenetics Dead Doctors Don't Lie
Hell's Kitchen and we're also looking at
it's all in your head there's 37
different diseases you get just in that
book it's all in your head and I know
I'm saying a lot faster and Rebecca's
trying to keep up there
now Hell's Kitchen goes from the
transition from wood and coal to fuel to
electricity and we're getting our our
nutritional minerals from wood ashes and
coal ashes and put in our Gardens and
also put on our food and when we went to
electricity suddenly now our source of
nutritional minerals that we have been
getting for thousands and thousands and
thousands of years
went away we no longer had access to
minerals in our food
and doctors didn't pay any attention oh
just eat well you're getting guarantee
you need
well
1936 you have sent a document 64 USA
came out and said uh-oh
we have we have a problem here
you sent a document 264 1936 we no
longer have sufficient amounts of
nutritional minerals in our farm cells
to support healthy human longevity
now do you think medical doctors paid
attention to that no
did your doctor send you an emergency
notice a postcard anything a phone call
to tell you to come in because he was
going to give a lecture to 25 people and
he wanted to be one of the 25 people
because you were going to him for a long
time no
he probably never said anything to you
about that there was no longer
nutritional minerals in our food because
we gave up the wood ashes and coal ashes
when we went to electricity
electricity is good for industry
electricity was good for manufacturing
electricity
and his side effects has killed more
people than all the wars that Humanity
has had since the beginning of recorded
time
so what you think about that one
okay with that said I think I've covered
what I want to cover I may have missed
one or so but I think I covered most of
them we have programs for each of these
diseases that are extremely common but
they're not genetic they're not unimmune
they're simple nutritional efficiency
and it's not unusual for people to have
high blood pressure arthritis diabetes
they'll start getting Alzheimer's
disease which is also a nutritional
deficiency of oh you're not going to
understand this one Alzheimer's disease
is a deficiency of cholesterol
cholesterol so that's why we have you
know we have the health of the brain and
heart pack but we also have I-26 it says
right on the label
gives you 25 of your data requirement of
cholesterol you do need to eat three
eggs as an adult three eggs twice today
with soft yolks not hard boil not Pride
and get these kids to be eating some
scrambled eggs and butter when they're
little
okay and give them we have the chewables
the vanilla very pleasant little kids
love them the chewables of the I-26 I
take a couple of those at lunch time
and so it's one of those things where
you can prevent all this stuff all this
stuff like um
um let's see here
Bruce Willis
you know he has this
FTD frontal temporal dementia which is
kind of a weird
um Alzheimer's disease which just
affects the part of the brain the side
of the brain but the back of the brain
is okay
that's because I guarantee you I don't
you know I didn't look at his records
but I guarantee you he was taking a
Stanton drug to lower cholesterol I
guarantee he was on a
cholesterol-restricted diet because he
may have had some blocked or arteries in
his heart and the doctors are trying to
tell him hey you got to get rid of all
that cholesterol out of your diet and we
can maybe prevent having to do a heart
transplant or something and he really
hit it hard and then he got all the
cluster on his brain went away and
that's why he's got
FTD it's not H negative Z it's not no
immune disease okay it's a nutritional
deficiency of
cholesterol okay well you mentioned that
little kids love the vanilla chewables
and I'm going to accept that because I'm
one of them
52 years old yes I am a little kid that
loves the I-26 the French vanilla
chewables
um so they are tasty I don't take them
at the same time that I eat my eggs I
have at least an hour from the time
before or after I take the eggs because
there's antibodies in our in our I-26
hyperimmune and then there's antibodies
also in the egg well I know that the
hyper they fight that's right
because the the egg itself
is like super fortified from the
chickens in the I-26 defending the
embryo
defending the embryo and there's a lot
of care that's taken into into those
animals as they're providing the
nutrition in the eggs that are then made
into the hyper immune so there's a lot
of research on that
um and you can go to daily withdoc.com
look up I-26 you'll find some more
information about that product as well
now Dr Wallach
all of these conditions that you
mentioned that are quote unquote due to
old age that people just accept
they don't need to accept it right see
I'm going to be 84 in two months and I
don't have any of those
because I've been taking these things
since I was nine years old
and I had many of them but I don't now
because I started listening to you
I know you as you asked me earlier in a
conversation when we were with a with a
client
um how many doctors did I used to go to
I mean I was seeing four and five
doctors a week
and then you ask me how many do you see
now I said just one
at least five days a week as well but
it's just one and it's you so look at
this
I think it was a I think it was a great
exchange Dr Wallach it took many many
years of pain and discomfort to get here
but folks once I found it I'm never
going back
missionary you're such a good missionary
because you went through all the bad
stuff that many families go through
and you found a way to get on the right
path and eliminate all those problems
and so you are speaking with personal
experience
oh most definitely personal experience
and now you just can't shut me up doc
and we have lots of people with hands up
today so we are going to definitely get
to some questions thank you so much for
that introduction Dr Wallach and
and providing information that is a
fallacy
when it comes to old age
yes it's a blessing for people to hear
this and they can take it to their
family and their friends and their
workmates and their Church mates
and we can save Humanity we can save the
world
but we need an army to do this I said
this many many years ago we needed an
army and that's why I chose the path
that I did because I couldn't do it all
myself and you were a five-star general
in the Army so I'm very very proud of
you
well thank you so much so if I'm a
five-star general what does that make
you
I'm sorry
a 10 star yes Ruth Allen Rose Allen says
you're a 10 star doc so
I'll take it I'll take it
I just want to remind everybody that if
you are in on live with us and you would
like to ask Dr Wallach a question go
ahead and go to that Zoom menu look for
reactions and raise your hand and
we were just talking about old age I
love the fact that more and more younger
people
are waking up Dr Wallach
and that includes the person with his
hand up right now but the first person
with his hand up and farhand welcome to
daily with Doc what question do you have
for Dr Wallach today
hey Rebecca thank you for that I really
appreciate it yeah um I I do have a
question before that yeah I started
learning about Dr Wallach in this
message uh 10 years ago when I was about
18. it was crazy because uh all
throughout high school you know I was
overweight not a weight issue you know
complex about that kind of just dealt
with it then I learned about Dr Wallach
and Beyond tangent and what it did for
someone you know the guy's name was uh
Aaron Dykes and he lost you know I used
to see him when he was huge very big
overly weight very large he said he took
minerals and then he lost all the weight
so I saw the before in The Afters and
then I said okay seems legit I'll Trust
it I'll just take it right as uh I think
people used to do back in the day a lot
of Skeptics nowadays but so I took the
Beyonce and tangerine and that's it
out of the 90 you know and I lost all
the weight just one day when I went to
college I was 18 right so 19 20 I went
to college and uh I just noticed one day
that I lost all the weight and I was
like skinny I couldn't believe myself so
it's pretty amazing it's been 10 years
since that and people say it's all in
your head but if this is a placebo hey
great it lasted 10 years while other
people are yo-yoing and going backwards
every couple of months and using all
their willpower to lose the weight and
gain it back and they give up and it's
been 10 years right uh so I don't know
people say testimonies this and that but
it's uh it's pretty amazing well I
appreciate you sorry you're sharing this
story because
um when you when you have a weight
problem that's a red warning light like
on the dashboard of your car
being overweight is not actually it's a
result of the problem okay and I suppose
you're missing the nutrients and you're
looking for food your body's telling you
look look you're not getting everything
you need look look and people are
looking by eating and they'll eat five
eight ten meals a day when snacking in
between and all that kind of stuff and
that's why they gain the weight you take
your nutrients suddenly now you don't
have that behavior which is called Pika
you can look it up in any dictionary p i
c a pika
and in horses they call it cribbing when
they chew in the top rail or their stall
or the fence babies and Cribs when
they're missing stuff because a mother
maybe they're nursing on the mother and
the mother's you know eating gluten and
not taking proper supplements and so it
doesn't have everything in the milk so
the baby starts chewing on the crib rail
so they call it cribbing that's where
that term came from tripping
yeah no it's amazing because I had the
same thing I just I would eat dinner and
then I would just crave eating chips
afterwards and there was no one to stop
me and if there was well I just go
myself I didn't need someone to take me
I'd always buy a bag of chips every day
once I started taking just the Beyond
Tangy Tangerine mind you I was eating
gluten as well so I don't know about my
absorption or whatever whatever at the
time you know 18 years old I took the
Beyond taking tangerine and the hunger
was gone like as you say and as other
people say so it's kind of strange when
I see people and they're you know they
could really benefit from losing weight
it would change their life like it
changed mine but they are so
apprehensive and they will deny that I
deny it's very strange because you could
just take it you don't have to believe
me uh like you say given 90 days and if
it changes your life then it then it
changes your life you should abandon
your old position and just uh yeah join
the ride or whatever you know or go yeah
it's very strange I can't thank you
enough
um it's one of it's farben right
yeah Farhan that's right for Han okay
yeah and the first thing that people say
when I say you know we can help you uh
lose that weight if you really want to
do it if you're prepared to put in a
little effort and they say well tell me
what it is I'll ask my doctor well the
doctor's got the one that got you in
trouble why would you ask them
it was so easy though just beyond Tangy
Tangerine I don't even know how
consistently I was using it honestly I
don't know if I was drinking it every
day to be honest thinking back but uh
I've noticed every time I get off the
Beyond tinga Tangerine the hunger comes
back irrationally right I just keep I
think about in my head it's kind of like
you're kind of high or whatever like
there's a feeling like I wanted you know
I see the things already in your house
75 minerals in it and some minerals
you're taking in that stop that cribbing
that stop the appetite
no doubt it's a it's very apparent you
just take it and you'll find out it's
nothing it's so weird to meet people
that deny because
just try it this could change your life
this could change your family's life why
are you denying them by rejecting this
information you can never come across
this again and live miserably a lot of
money you'll save a lot of money just by
getting off the bad foods bad foods
there's only benefits is vitamins and
minerals does it even claim weight loss
so when I tell you I can I couldn't
believe you're skeptical but like um
Rebecca said today that this is uh you
didn't just uh recently pop up you know
with the Advent of YouTube and uh I
guess money on YouTube you know
everyone's everyone's a doctor which is
true but they're all giving their take
and so this is Dr Wallace take but it's
been there for many many years
documented in Spades uh which blast you
know blows everyone away so
we spend 260 billion dollars a year just
treating obesity symptoms not preventing
it or curing it
we spend 260 billion dollars a year
where does it have 260 billion dollars
go it goes into your doctor's pocket
no doubt it's a parent it's not that you
can't deny 2023 which is amazing uh so
things a lot of negative things happen
but a lot of good things too where it's
hard to deny if you're a denier at this
point it's a you problem but it's such a
destructive you problem that you're
gonna hurt others by denying this
message and maybe saying you know Dr
Wall is a liar farhan's a liar his story
is not real Theo ratliff's a liar he
didn't consider playing the NBA and make
like you say millions of dollars he
either did or he didn't this is it this
is a now you gotta face that yourself
and that's you know meant you know kind
of a mental problem that people need to
get over it's hard but that's life life
sucks because of that anyways doctor
while I don't want to take your time too
much I really want to ask you questions
because my family is in terrible
condition I'm sharing your story for Han
that's the problem we really appreciate
you sharing the story
um you're worried how old are you now
I'm 28 almost 29. okay well 28 years old
29 years old
um you are you know more than most
doctors and so I'm very very
appreciative of you sharing your
experience your personal experience and
um your message has gotten out to to at
least thousands maybe millions of people
before you even stop talking
no doubt there's a lot of people that
deny me and say that I'm wrong and Dr
walks wrong on selenium look uh the fdaa
said it didn't work and but then I say
wait what about this research that Dr
Walling did and Dr Garrett trouser look
he committed his life to it
why don't you listen to their stories
they won't they deny but it's easier to
expose these people now 2023
unfortunately we have to talk this way
but
why are you denying it the information's
there you say I'm wrong and you'll bring
evidence to prove I'm wrong but you
didn't look at all at Dr Wallach or the
information that was here for years and
so why would you want to deny it anyways
this could change your life and your
loved one's life even if you didn't care
about yourself because people really
don't care about themselves nowadays at
least your family's life or your pet
people love their pets more than
themselves and humans this could save
your pet so why would you want to deny
why would you want to say it's not true
or something it's kind of weird but
people may need that perspective now but
uh
yeah okay well thank you sir we
appreciate this and um keep up the good
work and you know let's do some
conference calls with you and some of
your friends and Associates and things
let's get that message out there
yeah that'd be awesome because I am
going to graduate as a health coach soon
hopefully
that'd be nice yes you are farhand and
so did you have a question as well yes
really quick so I have a relative who is
about 60 years old they weigh 170 pounds
they're about five foot five inches tall
they have hyperthyroid
their doctor says they have high
cholesterol
they have some emotional problems let's
say she does it's a female she wakes up
to go to you she wakes up to go to the
bathroom
uncontrollably sometimes so she just
goes she has to wear a diaper
she is also she also had a stroke in the
past so she's paralyzed on the right
side so I'm wondering uh she really
wants to hopefully get better from the
Lisa paralysis of course right is
anything you could do for her yes the
first thing is she has osteoporosis of
the skull that's why she's getting up
three four five ten times a night to
urinate okay the skull is squeezing the
spinal fluid the spinal cord is telling
the the urinary bladder to urinate she
doesn't have a prostate gland so we
don't need to do a prostate biopsy
because girls don't have prostate glands
okay
and women have more of this issue than
men do and so doctors freak out because
they don't get to they don't get to make
any money on a woman who gets up eight
times a night to take a pee right now if
it was a man maybe right away they'd
schedule him for a prostate biopsy okay
but it's one of those things where it's
honestly process of the skull
and so
um uh also uh let's see here she's five
foot say five foot four
you know she tends to be five foot five
but yeah I would say five foot four I
don't know okay five foot five uh 170
pounds all right yeah so I'd have her
take two healthy brain and hard packs
per month two how they're Brandon hard
passage a month the photos through
everything twice a day
um we also want her to have the MSM two
bottles a month and take three of
breakfast treat lunch for dinner that's
going to help rebuild the skull I want
her to have a synaptive two bottles a
month so I can take three of those twice
a day so the brain cells will talk to
each other I want her to have our oceans
gold three of those twice today are a
few points Z through those points today
and they're from two different oceans
but they both have eight or nine
different seaweeds in them okay getting
all those minerals that make the thyroid
happy and then we have the seasoned salt
from Australia and we have the Himalayan
salt which is back in now
no one heard of heavily salts her food
now my first scientific paper
I wrote was a mass die off a 500 because
of a thyroid issue
okay
they died in one night 500. yeah heard
it okay and it was a sheep but they've
been getting nitrates which you can get
in bacon and ham and bologna and salami
and hot dogs and stuff like that they're
getting nitrates
from a fertilizer in the neighboring
farms and the temperature dropped to 16
and they all died of hypothermia they
were perfectly normal the day before
they were six months old they were ready
to be sheared after Christmas and after
the New Years they're going to go to
slaughter and that night the temperature
dropped from 45 down to 16 they all died
of hypothermia I wrote that up got it
published in a Veterinary Journal and
when I was in Africa working on the
White Rhino conservation project Marlon
Perkins you know Mutual Omaha Kingdom
showing Barry commoner the head of the
Department of biology at the University
assuming Washington University in St
Louis got a 25 million Grant from NIH
with that paper and came back they made
me the pathologist on the project and
that's how it all started
okay so we're very very familiar with
this and um please please please share
as much of this information as you can
with your friends
um some will
buy into it and take action and get the
benefit and some will just laugh and say
gotta ask my doctors first
and everybody makes their choices
you know everybody doesn't believe in
God everybody doesn't believe in
nutrition everybody doesn't believe in
everything and so it's one of those
things where people make their choices
and they pay the price so thank you
um and I think I answered your question
um let's see here a few coins disease
the radical the 90 essential nutrients
MSM
um and get rid of all the bad food so
you can absorb all that stuff okay
mashallah yeah thank you so much Dr uh
while I started to take everyone's time
if I just have so many questions
everyone's sick in my family and it's at
that place where they might go so it's
either you take the supplements now or
you're gonna go just like those people
just recently went
um
thank you thank you thank you thank you
we appreciate you and we look forward to
you continuing to help other people
because you know
um you earn an income from us as you
help other people we send you a check
every month it's one of those things uh
so you're going to be rewarded for what
you do thank you it's a no-brainer this
is amazing thank you Dr Wallace everyone
all right thank you so much so much for
coming on I look forward to hearing some
great testimonies from you as well from
your your family let's next go to Paul
Paul go ahead and unmute yourself you
are on live with Dr Wallach
hi there uh doc Wallach how are you
doing today okay Paul how can we help
you sir hi
um my this I I've been taking your
products a lot for the last Almost close
to 10 years now almost 11 years and I
could not believe how great they are
they've actually given me like my last
is almost what 40 50 pounds in the last
um almost decades or so because I'm
actually now a carrier hey thanks so
much
um but my questions they're actually
it's a two-parter uh the first part is
going to be uh for I guess I'm a postal
carrier working with the U.S Postal
Service
um this is for two of my co-workers
number one uh his name is uh Johnny and
he's I've been basically helping him out
so much uh regarding you know taking
your products he's been taking the Tangy
Tangerine 2.0 he's been also taking the
selenium and he's also been taking the
um what's that the floor FX and the um
ultimate daily uh enzymes or ultimate
enzymes
so basically he's been having a lot of
like stomach issues he's been having a
lot of digestive problems I've been
telling him telling him don't eat gluten
but he's been you know it's been so hard
for him to um to stop because his wife
his wife's basically been you know
telling him not to tell you oh don't
listen to that doggies apart no I I
don't I don't believe that at all but um
the question is is that what other
products are uh besides the um fire
effects and the um ultimate enzymes can
um take from a friend Johnny
well it's a little more complicated than
that but
um you do have to keep working on him to
get off of the gluten no we'd burn
around oats no fried foods no buckwheat
all that's got to go and here's where
um the books and the CDs come in
um you can ask his wife if she wants to
come on and ask a question plus nothing
you know it's toll-free okay oh yeah for
sure exactly but
um he's going to have to
you know just not eat what she's
providing and and start cooking his own
food or something like that otherwise
it's gonna die 25 years earlier exactly
Yeah so basically his wife has basically
been giving him a lot because he's
Mexican he's a lot of like flour
tortillas he's been eating pizza
hamburgers and all that I had pizza for
breakfast with my three eggs
but my pizza the crust okay was made on
beans
really all kinds of gluten-free pizzas
on the market you can go to any pizza
store and say I want my I don't want the
gluten-free pizza and they have three or
four different types of gluten-free
pizzas
of course yeah okay and so because
people stopped eating pizza because of
the wheat
you know the
um the bread part of the pizza okay the
pizza and so the same thing with
pancakes and waffles and I always tell
people eat like an Asian eat rice and
beans and sweet potatoes and and that
kind of stuff and you can eat pizza I
had I had pizza and eggs for breakfast
oh yeah yeah I eat pizza too but it's
mostly the cauliflower crust that the
cauliflower yeah well cauliflower means
that the the crust is made from
cauliflower there's no gluten in
cauliflower that's safe
of course it is safe it's actually much
more tastier than regular pizza with the
gluten it's just the consistency the
consistency is basically almost the same
as regular pizza okay we need to move on
to the second one oh sorry about that
um so on the second question uh I think
my friend Cheyenne I think she called
you one time on your old radio show back
in early November she has pre-diabetes
and basically wants to know what other
products she can take because right now
I believe she is taking sweeties okay
and I think I think she's like two two
times or three times a day I think and
she also I told her eat like lots of
like soft boiled soft and scrambled eggs
but if there's like any other um
she needs to get really gluten so she
can absorb the nutrients okay so we'd
run around oats eat cauliflower
it's really delicious yep very delicious
and then you know she she needs to have
rice
sweet potatoes that kind of stuff and um
the um
uh sweeties it's perfect it has the
nutrients that are necessary to prevent
and reverse
Type 2 Diabetes Type 2 diabetes which
makes up 98 to 99 depending on the
community 90 to 99 of the diabetic
population
is totally 100 a nutritional deficiency
there are no genetics involved there's
no autoimmunity involved and your body's
not going to attack on itself and
there's no even if everybody in your
family's got diabetes because they're
all eating the same way
okay of course yeah and so if they're
all eating the same way and they live in
the same place and nutritional minerals
do not occur in a uniform blanket around
the cusp of the earth they occur in
veins like gold and silver and so what
if you live in a place where there's
none of those nutrients plants do not
make minerals plants make vitamins amino
acids and fatty acids but plants do not
make minerals you're dependent on what
may be or may not be in the soil and so
the only way you can
cover the blank spots is to
supplement and take all 90 essential
nutrients then you know you're getting
it all no matter where you live
of course I mean that's what I've been
already like emphasizing that almost
every day but I'm just making sure that
they get that in their head and I I
wanted them just I'm dead serious
because I mean sometimes I get the
feeling that they're not taking me very
seriously but I wanted to be sure you
can be an angel I mean there's a lot of
people that don't
take God's advice and so yeah you
shouldn't feel too bad if they all don't
take your advice I mean they do the same
thing to me they say well I gotta ask
your doctor I said well you're not going
to get the right information by doing
that but you know it's a free country do
what you want but I've done my job I've
given you information and I didn't
charge anything part let's see how much
your doctor charges you for the
misinformation yeah that's gonna be like
you know a big big difference this makes
a big difference for sure okay well God
bless I think we've um answered all the
questions there for you Paul thank you
so much it's keep in contact because
it's great to hear and I feel like
yourself with a good story thank you
yeah I'm almost I'm going to be turning
40 this August so basically I've been
doing this for almost the last decade so
I'm really really you know appreciative
for what 10 years
almost 10 going close to 111. yeah okay
yeah so you don't look like you're How
old uh well right now I'm 39 but I'm
gonna be 40. yeah you look like you're a
teenager do people I know that for a
fact did people tell you that well they
think that I'm like a young 20 year old
yeah yeah you do you look like you're 18
to 20 years old so that's great so it's
a good say you say look Marjorie
um I'm four years old but I look like
I'm 20. wow you're going growing older
every day you want to look younger and
younger every day as opposed to older
and older every day do what I'm doing
and she'll listen to them of course
definitely and Becca you're doing a
great job with this Zoom call I mean
this has been filled a lot of the void
that has been left by the radio show and
I hope you continue on the great work
and um keep up at it with a doc because
he's number one and he's my favorite and
I really appreciate you doc thank you
sir we appreciate you and all the work
you're doing because all right it's a
beautiful story and of course Rebecca is
a five-star general in the Army and if
you kind of you know grow your own
business with the youngin don't take
long you can be a health coach you can
you know you should talk to uh um Paul
about his health coach thing okay oh
definitely for sure I've been like you
know been like a mentor for them and
basically they take my advice to to
questions on I'll be out let's get you
to be a health coach and so you get a
certificate and it'll blow people's mind
oh definitely for sure doc okay God
bless you sir and thank you thank you
thank you thank you so much I'll see you
soon bye thank you so much Paul
well Dr Wallach there's there's so many
people that you know were able to reach
and be and they're all it's like new
people coming out he's been doing this
longer than I have been helping people I
think that's absolutely fabulous and
he's like what 12 years younger than I
that's okay he looks like he's 18 to 20
years old
and he's 40. is that crazy I was
thinking 25 not 18. come on now
but yes I think it's great it's great I
mean I'd been
told by several people they don't
believe that I'm 50 52. no you look like
you're 30. I don't feel it
so well thank you Dr Wallach let's so
I've got a hand or a question here in
the comments let's see if we can get to
it really quick
um so just a mom says my mom or my son
14 years old has an anaphylactic allergy
to tree nuts diagnosed by an MD at the
age of 22. what is trima
tree nuts oh tree nuts okay three nuts
pecans walnuts cashews
um
hazelnuts those things okay what
happened
um she doesn't say what happened
but at 14. you know you just get
diarrhea does he get asthma do you get
diarrhea did he get pain okay so
anaphylactic doctor while like it stop
he stops breathing oh
that's a symptom
yeah that might be something kind of
serious to you know take note of
the first thing he should do is avoid
eating nuts
come on now let me finish you're
interrupting
um so he's currently at 14 175 pounds at
five foot four
um can he ever become not allergic to
tree nuts and how do we go about this
so they are on some of the youngevity
products but Dr Wallach so we're looking
at a young man he has allergies to tree
nuts
um
175 pounds five foot four what are your
recommendations so allergies are found
in the gut
are caused by a compromised digestive
system
where where would you go where would you
start
the first thing he's got to do and the
family's got to do the whole family okay
including himself he they've got to get
rid of all the bad foods no fried foods
no processed Meats no oils no gluten so
we brought around those so sugar no
carbonated drinks even the diet one's
got to go or carbonated water's got to
go
and
let's see here I want him to start out
with something simple
um I don't believe there's tree nuts in
the healthy brain and heart back I don't
think there's no I don't believe so yeah
there's 215 nutrients in there but I
don't believe there's any nuts in there
and then so we'd have to double check
that but I don't believe there is and
then uh if he weighs 175 pounds you say
I want him to have to the health brain
and heart pasture I'm going to take a
full dose twice a day and then I also
want them to have the
um let's see here
synaptive
okay two bottles of that a month so you
can take three twice a day so brain
cells can talk to each other
I also want him to take our kind of
anti-inflammatory stuff okay
um what do you like for any inflammatory
stuff
well the the MSM is very anti
antari so is the glucogel
add in here
here he is also asthmatic and has eczema
so
we're talking about efas
we're talking efas for sure so he could
have three three times a day I'd have
him take I take three twice a day of the
efas and and three twice a day of the fa
plus I only weigh 142. so he could do
that
okay and um
let's start there
all right well thank you Dr Wallach
that'll help just the mom uh get some
some more nutrition into her little guy
so that he can start creating a
different Health journey and I know Dr
Wallach that it's time for you to go to
your next program so thank you again so
much for squeezing Us in here we love
you we appreciate you and we'll see you
tomorrow yes well thank you so much for
all you do and thank you for the team
and and thank you for all of our
followers it's really asking great
questions I'm very proud of everybody
and thank you thank you thank you very
much God bless yes God bless you too Dr
Wallach and if I can just get my
co-hosts on here folks
we provide a lot of information Dr
Wallach speaks very quickly I understand
that you can go and find the replays for
our programs on daily with doc.com there
click up there where it says health
articles and then you can select daily
with Doc we have a lot of articles that
contribute to Better Health that you are
not going to find in many other
locations and these are tried and true
recommendations by health professionals
that have come over into the world of
nutrition because they have realized
that there is great great value in it
and it helps them be a better
I it's just a better practitioner in
helping their clients their patients and
holding true to that Do no harm in the
Hippocratic Oath that they took when
they became a medical professional again
go to daily withdoc.com but if you were
invited by somebody specific get back
with them
they have their own way of ordering the
daily with Doc we are here for a as a
resource to the community as a whole but
we want to make sure that the person
that brought you to this information
is able to help to continue to be a
resource to you and help you in getting
what you need to write a better health
Journey on this half of myself Becker
Kozak Rebecca Dukes
sorry about that and my co-host Sherry
Browning Marilyn pazera and Ruth Ellen
Sanchez and of course the great Dr Joel
Wallach thank you so much for joining us
and join us again tomorrow
at not at 12 p.m Pacific Time on daily
with Doc zoom.com if you're not
following us already on rumble or
YouTube or Facebook make sure that you
do critical Health news that is our
Channel
and we just do this because one we love
people
two we know that there's better options
that you're not going to hear anywhere
else three
be empowered folks there is so much that
you yourself can do on your own
without a piece of paper prescribing
your chemical until next time bye for
now
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign